Yeah,
California should do to fix its economy.
I think first you've got to recognize
California has enormous potential.
It has a,
it's a great environment.
It's very open to new ideas.
Silicon Valley,
it's got great universities,
great.
Um,
uh,
both the University of California in the
private universities.
So the potential is tremendous.
What we really need to do in California
is to deal with a serious budget
problem,
which means spending,
grows too much and then taxes rise and
that tends to drive out businesses and
ultimately as harmful to the state.
So I would say number one in terms of
the question is,
is put some limit on the growth of
spending population growth.
Plus inflation is one way to do it,
uh,
that would prevent the ups and downs in
the,
in the deficit spending usually rises
rapidly when tax revenues arrive and
then tax revenues fall off and you've
got this huge deficit.
So control the growth of spending number
one.
Number two,
it put in some,
uh,
tax reforms to prevent the ups and downs
and revenues to be so great.
And here we've got a huge cyclical,
a performance in tax revenues.
So I would adopt some of the proposals
of the recent California Tax Commission
that a governor Schwarzenegger,
I introduced,
and Third Education,
k 12 it slipping in California.
I think it's not a matter of spending a
lot of spent in California.
It's really demanding more
accountability.
I'd like to see a program where there's
more for teachers and less for
administration on.
I think that would do a lot of them.